nuestro país es maravilloso tiene un
futuro increíble adelante pero la verdad
es que a veces me preocupa algo bastante
y es que no me queda claro con quién
queremos compartir ese país
si lo queremos compartir con todos os lo
queremos compartir solamente con las
personas que son y piensan igual que
nosotros yo la verdad que lo que siento
es que en lugar de un país somos como
una división entre bandos no es cierto
entre bandos que no se reconocen unos a
otros como interlocutores válidos y
cuyos integrantes no necesariamente
encuentran muchas cosas en común con los
otros bandos por ejemplo últimamente nos
sentimos todos muy orgullosos de la
gastronomía peruana por ejemplo pero no
hay mucho más que eso que nos haga
sentir que todos formamos parte de lo
mismo
a veces pasan cosas como la inauguración
de los recientes juegos panamericanos en
lima y uno ve que somos parte de este
pasado milenario y de estas culturas
extraordinarias que nos han antecedido y
aparece este sentimiento increíble pero
no nos dura mucho y al poco tiempo
regresamos a nuestra realidad que es la
de ser un país dividido desconectado con
este enfrentamiento permanente entre
todos y le voy a contar como veo yo esta
dinámica en tres ejemplos concretos el
primero es la política en el perú las
identidades políticas no son a favor de
algo sino típicamente son en contra de
alguien no es cierto
el anti no necesariamente está mal por
ejemplo en estos días es bastante bueno
que seamos anti corrupción
pero el problema es cuando somos
únicamente anti y no hay nada en lo que
podamos decir estamos todos a favor de
y eso un poco se ve en la política
porque nuestros actores políticos no
encuentran las maneras de generar estos
consensos mínimos que necesitamos para
avanzar como país están permanentemente
enfrentados enemistados el segundo
ejemplo que les quería es el del fútbol
del fútbol local uno va a ver un partido
entre clubes peruanos y escucha como las
barras se insultan unas a otras en el
estadio no es cierto y uno se pregunta
por qué por qué no se sienten
satisfechos con el hecho de estar viendo
un buen espectáculo y ver a su equipo
jugar eventualmente ver a su equipo
ganar sino que tienen la necesidad de
que el equipo opuesto no solamente sea
derrotado sino sea humillado que lo
golpeen y que no lo dejen levantarse y
la razón por la cual ocurre eso es
porque no lo están viendo como un rival
si no lo están viendo como un enemigo y
la diferencia entre estas dos cosas es
el bien importante porque contra un
rival uno puede competir en una
contienda deportiva y puede ganar o
puede perder ambas son resultados
digamos válidos de esa competencia pero
contra un enemigo uno no está en
competencia está en guerra y la guerra
es distinta en la guerra lo que tenemos
que hacer es destruir al bando opuesto
tenemos que
darle tan duro que no se levante porque
en las guerras a veces es mejor no dejar
prisioneros y el tercer ejemplo que les
quería decir es el del tráfico manejar
en línea es como transitar en un campo
minado uno siente que en cualquier
momento va a recibir una agresión de
alguien más y ni siquiera queda claro
cuáles son los bandos es como que es una
guerra de todos contra todos
y lo que hace esto es que uno asuma que
la otra persona el otro conductor va a
tratar de sacar provecho de uno y por
tanto la disposición natural que uno
tiene hacia esa otra persona es de
desconfianza y no de confianza
si no ve todos estos ejemplos a mí lo
que me lleva a preguntarme es si es que
hay algo de cierto en esta pregunta que
escuchado tantas veces de que el peor
enemigo de un peruano es otro peruano y
me fastidia tener que reconocer que en
muchos sentidos hemos dejado que sea
cierto y yo no pretendo aquí explicarles
todas las razones por las cuales eso es
así de repente requeriría un té completo
para eso pero si hay una parte de este
fenómeno que para mí es bastante
interesante la que medicado los últimos
años a analizar y tiene que ver con la
manera como discutimos como debatimos
entre peruanos
no podéis ir puede ser bastante duro
pero el tipo de debate público que
tenemos en el perú es una vergüenza es
realmente pobre
por muchas razones pero una razón es
porque no hemos entendido todavía para
qué sirve el debate como vemos todo como
esta guerra entre bandos no es cierto
esta es la lógica con la que entendemos
la realidad pensamos que el debate es lo
mismo pero el debate en realidad es una
herramienta para las sociedades que les
permite acercarse a la verdad que les
permite entender mejor cómo es esa
realidad en la que se desenvuelven
finalmente es una herramienta de
progreso si no existiese el debate si no
se entendiese de esa manera todavía
seguiremos pensando que la tierra es
plana o que el sol gira alrededor
nuestro porque nadie se habría atrevido
digamos en algún momento a disputar ese
paradigma dominante
alguien efectivamente hizo eso de
repente no le dieron la razón tan rápido
pero finalmente se la dieron y así el
mundo progreso y así es como progresa el
mundo a partir del debate
el problema es que en el perú no estamos
dispuestos
a que se dé esta competencia entre ideas
pero preferiríamos que las personas que
tienen ideas opuestas a las nuestras no
existan que desaparezcan
no queremos que ese bando sea parte de
este país si uno le pregunta a un
peruano promedio por ejemplo si estaría
dispuesto a recortar la libertad de
expresión es decir a censurar a la
persona que opina distinto culturalmente
muy probablemente lo haría casi que de
inmediato afortunadamente no lo puede
hacer porque la libertad de expresión
está consagrada en la constitución
peruana
pero si esa misma persona tuviese que
debatir con su adversario ideológico no
lo haría para entender sus razones para
entender sus argumentos sino que lo
haría para hablarle encima para tratar
de ridiculizar lo para tratar de trapear
el piso con sus ideas eventualmente para
insultarlo
y todo esto se ha vuelto peor con un
fenómeno relativamente reciente que son
las redes sociales las redes sociales
llegaron con esta promesa de
democratizar la expresión política que
todo el mundo pudiese expresarse lo
cierto y efectivamente eso ha ocurrido
pero de un tiempo a esta parte se han
convertido en este espacio tóxico donde
la gente no quiere debatir no quiere
escuchar al otro lo único que quiere es
insultar y descalificar repente es la
experiencia de algunos de ustedes
ciertamente la vida
el problema con las redes sociales es
que el sistema incentivos es el
incorrecto no es cierto tenemos este
incentivo para polarizar nos para tratar
de ser cada vez más extremos en nuestras
posiciones
y no solamente pasa con la gente que por
ejemplo no se identifica que no tiene la
valentía de poner su nombre lo cierto
pasa también con los líderes opinión
pasa con los políticos con las
autoridades que decían ellas mismas
hundirse en el fango y participar de ese
tipo de debate no yo liamos las redes
sociales las puertas del infierno porque
es lo que nos permite ver lo peor de la
humanidad ahora
cuando tomo digamos estas distintas
cosas que les he venido diciendo no el
hecho que en el perú estamos siempre
enfrentados entre bandos que se
entienden como enemigos cuando vemos el
tipo de debate público que tenemos
cuando vemos como las redes sociales
empeoran todo esto yo me pregunto qué
hacemos para solucionar este problema y
me pregunto si es un problema de las
personas o es un problema del diseño del
sistema porque es bien fácil pensar que
es un problema de las personas y decir
lo que pasa con el perú todos somos unos
ignorantes y no sabemos debatir la
educación que tenemos es muy mala
intuitivamente hace sentido pero no es
tan cierto de hecho hay estudios que
demuestran que las personas con mayores
niveles de instrucción son las que peor
debaten o las que más propensión tienen
a utilizar estas malas artes del debate
entonces sin duda hay algo que tiene que
ver con las personas pero también pienso
yo es principalmente un problema del
diseño del sistema de los incentivos del
contexto en el que discutimos y por eso
yo desde hace algún tiempo
ya hace unos cinco años más o menos
surgió esta idea como inicialmente como
un hobby pero cree esto que hoy se llame
el comité de lectura que es una
comunidad que tiene hoy a decenas de
miles de personas
a las cuales básicamente lo que hacemos
es le hacemos un servicio de curaduría
de contenidos porque en la prensa y en
los medios y en las redes sociales en
general ustedes puede encontrar todo
tipo de basura digamos información que
apela al morbo al amarillismo al
sensacionalismo y aveces no queda claro
termina pasando que perdemos mucho
tiempo discutiendo tonterías y aquí lo
que hay que hacer es hay que seleccionar
aquellos temas que realmente ameritan
discusiones importantes y eso es lo que
hacemos y la fortaleza que tiene esta
comunidad es universidad porque hay hay
economistas hay políticos hay
empresarios hay líderes opinión hay
abogados filósofos educadores hay de
todo hay gente mayor
hay gente menor hay gente de izquierda
de derecha de centro hay gente de
distintas partes del país y de otras
partes del mundo en fin
tratamos de que sea lo más diversa
posible y lo que hacemos nosotros es
moderar esta experiencia de debate
precisamente para cambiar los incentivos
y para cambiar el contexto y no
intervenimos somos neutrales lo que
tratamos de hacer es que hayan ciertas
reglas mínimas de civilidad por decirlo
alguna manera para que cuando la gente
debata
sienta que tiene la seguridad de poder
expresar sus discrepancias sin temor a
ser por ejemplo insultado
y una de las cosas que hemos aprendido
en el camino es que está bien que las
discusiones empiecen por ejemplo en las
redes pero es fundamental que las
discusiones terminen de manera
presencial con la gente mirándose en las
caras porque cuando uno debate a través
de una plataforma virtual
puede uno tener pues la valentía de
insultar
descaradamente digamos al otro bando y
de repente no le va a pasar nada pero
cuando uno tiene al opositor al frente
ya no es tan fácil es cierto no es tan
fácil insultarlo a su cara entonces lo
que hemos hecho hace más o menos un año
es tenemos estos eventos que se llaman
el cara a cara del comité de lectura
donde invitamos a gente representativa
de todo el espectro ideológico y les
ponemos un sticker que tiene su nombre y
tiene un color y ese color simboliza su
posición ideológica entonces es
conservador es de un color liberal es
otro color progresista es de otro color
etcétera y luego los emparejamos de modo
que cada quien tenga una pareja que sea
de un color diferente o alguien que no
ha conocido que nunca ha visto en su
vida y así los forzamos a debatir con
personas que probablemente tengan
posiciones diferentes a las suyas y
vamos soltando temas polémicos
el matrimonio igualitario el proyecto
minero tía maría lo que fuera que fuese
importante de un determinado momento y
los hacemos debatir por unos 10-15
minutos y es como un sistema 'speed
dating' de ahí van rotando no se van
chocolate ando
y al final hacemos una ronda abierta y
les preguntamos qué aprendieron del otro
lado si es que hay algo que aprendieron
del otro lado
a veces pasa a veces no
finalmente
lo que terminamos haciendo es que
desarrollen que brote digamos un poco de
ese instinto empático digamos que
tenemos las personas que inclusive a
pesar la discrepancia podemos tratar de
entender quién está en frente
cuando yo recién lance o convoque a la
primera reunión de estos eventos varios
amigos míos
líderes de opinión me dijeron de precio
de empacar lo que estás haciendo pero yo
no puedo ir de ninguna manera porque he
visto la lista de invitados y hay
personas a las que no puede ver ni en
pintura
y yo lo que le decía pues ese es
exactamente lo que estamos buscando
estamos buscando que vayas y te juntes
con esas personas el lugar estar
insultándolas en la en twitter no anda y
conocerlas
porque la incomodidad es un elemento
fundamental del debate el buen debate si
uno no se siente incómodo debatiendo es
porque no está debatiendo con el
adversario correcto porque está
debatiendo de repente con alguien que
tiene una posición relativamente similar
a la suya
entonces como les explicaba lo que
estamos tratando de hacer acá es es como
usted cuando ustedes escuchan esta nota
que siempre se cuenta del chófer que en
su país maneja como una bestia no cierto
pero cuando se va a otro país y alquila
un auto súbitamente cumple con todas las
reglas de tránsito
un poco es así sea queremos generar ese
espacio donde la gente se autorregula y
tenga la disposición de poder debatir de
manera segura
y por supuesto que hay incomodidad pero
hay que aclarar que la incomodidad no
tiene que ver con la incomodidad tiene
que ver con enfrentarse ideas diferentes
no debiera tener que ver con enfrentarse
insultos de otras personas eso está
prescrito y afortunadamente no nos ha
pasado hasta ahora lo que sí me pasa a
mí personalmente es que aún usted sabe
yo tengo un podcast que sale en las
mañanas y a veces le llegan mensajes de
gente que me manda pues todo tipo de
insultos porque no está de acuerdo en mi
opinión no yo resumo las noticias y
comento un poco
y cuando recibo estos insultos
lo que hago es les respondo con respeto
y les digo muchas gracias por escribir
me parece que tu posición es válida
cuéntame un poquito más porque quiero
entender tus argumentos y cuando eso
pasa la gente se desarma porque no no
tiene no les entra en la cabeza la
posibilidad de que ante un insulto una
persona responda como algo distinto a un
insulto y a veces lo que termina pasando
es que me dicen algo así como mira este
lamento mucho haber empezado así esta
conversación pero afortunadamente siento
que aprendí un poco
me siento un poco más confiado ahora de
poder tener esta conversación con
quienes está en el lado en el lado
opuesto
cuando yo les cuento todo esto de
repente ustedes están pensando pues si
me resulta familiar pasa eso en el perú
el perú debatimos así de mal
pero yo no soy uno de ellos yo soy una
persona racional yo soy la persona
razonable no insulto no descalifico
y probablemente sea el caso si éste está
hecho bien su selección entre los
invitados
pero yo lo que les preguntaría es lo
siguiente
como son sus redes sociales sus redes
sociales son un reflejo de la diversidad
del país de la diversidad ideológica del
país o son un reflejo de ustedes porque
si ustedes tienen en sus redes sociales
solamente personas que piensan más o
menos igual con diferencias marginales
entonces no están dispuestos a vivir a
plenitud lo que significa la experiencia
de vivir en democracia porque están
generando estas burbujas no cierto estas
cámaras de eco donde lo único que hacen
es escuchar a la gente que ya tiene
igual que ustedes y están
retroalimentando sus propios prejuicios
y esa es la costumbre y estamos
perdiendo en el perú estamos generando
este estamos dividiendo nos en bandos
como les decía no cierto estamos
trivializando el país y cada uno
solamente quiere escuchar a su tribu y
así no podemos progresar como país
hay otro tema que les quería mencionar
qué tiene que ver con los políticos
yo a veces por ejemplo cuando se muere
un político en el perú leo el obituario
no es cierto que sale en el diario y
dice algo así como este político siempre
fue consecuente con sus ideas y se dice
como si fuese algo bueno no es cierto
porque claro en una política como la
nuestra donde la tradición es que las
los políticos cambian de posición todo
el tiempo no es cierto que sean unas
veletas que sean hipócritas claro una
persona que siempre defendió lo mismo
entonces se sale del molde en cierto
pero la consecuencia llevada al extremo
es un problema porque eso puede ser una
demostración de que una persona nunca
tuvo la hidalguía con la honestidad
intelectual de reconocer que estaba
equivocado en algo que nunca dijo el
otro lado de repente si tiene mejores
argumentos que los míos y eso es lo que
nos pasa todo el tiempo nadie está
dispuesto a aceptar que el otro lado
tiene la razón porque si estamos en
guerra no es cierto es como darle el
triunfo al otro lado y eso no lo
admitimos como una posibilidad
y yo estoy preocupado como le decía hace
bastante tiempo por este tema y creo que
con todas las cosas buenas que tenemos
como país con todo el potencial que nos
hace ser un país increíble en muchos
sentidos no vamos a llegar a ningún lado
si no resolvemos la manera como
discutimos si no podemos tener un debate
mínimamente civilizado no vamos a
progresar o cuanto caso no lo vamos a
hacer al ritmo que quisiéramos
por eso yo creo que tenemos que hacer
tres cosas y ya se las he venido de
alguna manera diciendo en la charla la
primera es que tenemos que ponernos a
las opiniones diferentes no podemos ir
viendo cada uno nuestra burbuja y hacer
como qué pueblo más no existe ya eso no
puede seguir siendo así
lo segundo es que tenemos que empezar a
asumir que si podemos estar equivocados
y que no tiene nada de malo que estemos
equivocados si un país la gente no asume
eso como una posibilidad
las discusiones tampoco no van a ningún
lado y lo tercero que para mí es lo más
importante es que está bien que los
peruanos seamos o nos entendamos unos a
otros como rivales
podemos ser rivales en la política
podemos ser rivales en el mercado nos
llevan contra las empresas o podemos a
rivales en los deportes pero lo que
nunca debiera pasar es que entre
peruanos nos sintamos que somos enemigos
gracias